todas estas manos del presidente
y donald trump no pone su nombre en el
proyecto de ley de estímulo cerca de 14
millones de estadounidenses pierden los
beneficios por desempleo
un acuerdo había sido logrado luego de
meses de negociaciones tortuosa entre
los demócratas y republicanos en el
congreso
pero a inicios de esta semana el
presidente de trump se rehusó a firmar
el proyecto de ley diciendo que los 600
dólares de ayuda estipulados para los
individuos no eran suficientes
les le pido al congreso que enmiende
este proyecto de ley y aumente los
ridículamente bajos 600 dólares a 2000
el proyecto de ley que ahora planean
enviar a mi escritorio es muy diferente
de lo previsto es realmente una
desgracias tres palabras que tomaron al
congreso por sorpresa swap no se opuso
al acuerdo el pasado lunes cuando fue
sometido a votación y de hecho eran los
demócratas los que habían insistido en
que los estadounidenses deberían recibir
un monto más alto de berna créanlo o no
los demócratas están de acuerdo con el
presidente 600 dólares no son
suficientes para los individuos que la
han pasado mal durante los últimos siete
meses y no son suficientes para darle un
impulso a las necesidades de nuestra
economía con el veto trompón e millones
de dólares de ayuda económica en el
limbo incluyendo 286 mil millones para
las familias y los desempleados 284 mil
millones para los pequeños negocios y 70
mil millones para las vacunas y pruebas
de kobe 19 también dentro del acuerdo
está la pausa en las órdenes de
desalojos sin ella millones de personas
perderán sus casas
el proyecto de ley fue acordado por 1.4
billones de dólares lo que significa que
el gobierno estaría forzado a cerrar el
lunes si trump decide no firmar